[Music]
welcome to the session thanks for
joining us I'm a pulse ox enema product
lead on cloud machine learning team I'm
Sarah Robinson I'm a developer advocate
on the Google cloud platform team and
here we are today to talk about how
cloud machine learning can transform
your customer service experience but
before I get started let me see how many
people were listening to Diane green in
yesterday's keynote so as the show of
hand I'm going to ask you how many
products and features we released last
year in 2016
those who believe is released less than
200 Grazer and please between 200 to 400
year a few about thousand now we around
between final eight to six hundred
that's the number so we release more
than 450 products and features last year
alone and today as the conference
released more than 50 of those so great
momentum for us and this is what we are
going to talk about how specifically in
this session there are three things I
want you to take away number one I want
you to understand some of the new
products and features that we have
launched and how they can transform
customer service number two we will walk
you through a case study where one of
our customers Ricardo is using some of
these tools to transform customer
service for their customers and the
third one we will talk about the PWC
case study where a customer is using and
building an end-to-end field service
solution support as a product manager
you probably get a ton of feedback
coming from all sorts of channels yes oh
in fact at Google across-the-board gets
more than 10,000 service request
customer service with touch points on a
single day and that's and so as I saw we
Google we believe great customer service
is important part of a great product
experience so we monitor our channels
not only in the traditional
email and phone phone calls in terms of
customer requests but we also monitor
Facebook Twitter and so on and so forth
but to get a differentiated customer
service experience it's not only
important to monitor all the different
channels the customer can reach you it's
also important to make sure the customer
generated the customer request journey
is differentiated across the lifecycle
and what is a typical customer journey
look like so let's take an example again
it readies by company by company but all
we just did a very high-level view of
how it could look like in a situation
like this so on the on one side you have
customer touch points across different
channels as I said whether it could be a
phone or an email or Twitter feed coming
in it gets the may 1st thing you
typically do when a customer request
comes in is try to understand who the
customer is so typically you will tap
into your CRM system to understand who
the customer is is the next level is not
every customer requests can be
prioritized as high priority
so you understand try to understand how
what the priority of the request is and
then you route that request to the
appropriate csr so if this thing is
pretty simplified view but across these
four steps you still have huge
opportunity for machine learning to make
an impact number one on the side on the
at the left of the funnel you will see
that most of the customer requests are
well understood if they are coming from
email phone is completely handled
differently how do you make sure if
using if I can transcribe all my audio
calls into text and then run some
analysis there is a huge opportunity
there number two if you typically we can
route your customer request without even
understanding what's in it what if you
could use natural language to understand
and pass what's being said in the
customer service requests and the third
if you want to route your product of
customer service request if you know if
it is about shipping or if it is about
pricing you can route it to different
csr again huge under a huge leap of
improvement in productivity if you can
do if you can route it intelligently so
those are the opportunities so at Google
we
have provided you a set of portfolio
machine learning portfolio that helps
you tackle a lot of these problems on
the left hand side we have what we call
pre-trained machine learning models
where you can you don't need a data
science degree to actually use some of
these model these are restful api is
that you can call using single line
simple line of code and what you need
what it helps you do is understand
what's in an image or audio or video on
the right-hand side of the other of this
spectrum is if you want to build a
custom model for your own particular
need if you want to do a plot text
classifier to router tickets differently
you probably will use a open source deep
learning framework like tensorflow
and run it on the cloud machine learning
engine and that's the full spectrum that
gives you the opportunity to build to
your need so to talk about each of these
key products that are useful I'll hand
it over to Sarah to walk you through the
products thanks support so I'm going to
cover the cloud speech and the cloud
natural language API so those are
particularly relevant to customer
service we'll start with the speech API
how many of you have used the ok Google
functionality on your phone anybody here
looks like a little more than half so
the speech API essentially exposes the
functionality of ok Google to developers
and lets you do speech to text
transcription in over 80 languages so
here's an overview of the features of
the speech API you can transcribe text
in over 80 languages and variants and it
supports both batch and streaming modes
you can send it a complete audio file
you can also send it a stream of
continuous audio and it'll transcribe
that audio as the stream is coming in it
can detect an appropriate content in
your audio and then you can once you've
got the text you can analyze it with
other Google Cloud machine learning API
which I'm going to talk about
momentarily so this is what a request
for the speech API would look like in
Python to create your service request
and there's a couple different things
you need to pass the speech API you tell
it the encoding type of the audio here
we're using linear 16 the sample rate in
her
and then you pass it the language code
if you leave this parameter out it will
default to English otherwise if you're
using a language other than English you
just need to tell it the language code
of the language you would like to
transcribe and then you pass it either a
Google Cloud Storage URI of your audio
file or you can give it a local file to
transcribe and that's all you have to do
so the beauty of these machine learning
API is like to call them friendly
machine learning is they give you access
to these pre trained models which is a
single REST API request you don't really
have to understand what's going on in
the underlying model so that's a speech
API so you're with the speech API were
transcribing audio once we get that text
transcription we likely don't want to
stop there there's probably more
analysis we want to do on it especially
in the customer service industry once we
get our customers call maybe it's a
voicemail we're going to want to do more
analysis on that text and that's where
the natural language API comes into play
what it does is it lets you extract
entities sentiment and syntax from text
I'm going to take a deeper dive into
those three features that it lets you do
so for the entities example on the big
Harry Potter fan and so I take in the
sense about JK Rowling from her
Wikipedia page and let's see what the
entity extraction endpoint will give us
back if we send it this sentence so it's
able to extract these five entities and
it's going to give us some JSON data on
each one and one thing you'll notice
here is that those first three entities
are actually all the same thing they're
actually just different ways of saying
JK Rowling's named Robert Galbraith is
actually a pen name she used for later
book series but I won't get into that
so they all point to the same entity so
for the entity data we get back the name
the type of entity it is she's a person
and then some metadata on her so the API
won't necessarily return metadata if
it's an entity
that doesn't have a Wikipedia page but
in this case there definitely is a
Wikipedia page for JK Rowling so it'll
give us the mid-21st century for
British it maps it to a location we also
get the mid-80s you are L and notice
that the Wikipedia URL points to the
United Kingdom Wikipedia page so if
instead the text said UK or United
Kingdom would still point to the same
entity and then for Harry Potter looks
similar we get the entity type location
that should actually be person its
mistake and then it points to a Harry
Potter with the pedia page the second
thing that the natural language API lets
you do is analyze the sentiment of
something so something that is useful
for is customer feedback in this case
this is something it might be on a
restaurant review the food was excellent
I would definitely go back so it returns
two values for us to understand the
sentiment the first is magnitude and
this tells us the overall strength of
the sentiment regardless of whether it's
positive or negative and this will
change based on the length of the text
it can range from 0 to infinity this
text is pretty short which is why we get
a pretty small number there the score
value is going to tell us whether it's
positive or negative so this ranges from
negative 1 to 1 and we can see this is a
pretty positive statement so it's almost
all the way at 1 and then the final
feature of the natural language API is
analyzing syntax and this gets a bit
more into the linguistic details of text
and this visualization is actually
pulled from the product page for the
national language API so anybody can go
here and try it out create a
visualization with your own text without
having to write any code to get started
there's a bunch of data it returns here
on the syntax of your text so the
sentence we have is the natural language
API helps us understand text and let's
start with that top row those green
arrows that's what we call a dependency
parse tree which basically tells us how
the words in the sentence relate to each
other which words depend on other words
in the sentence that second row is the
parse label and that's basically the
role of each word in the sentence so we
can see that helps is the root verb API
is the nominal subject the third row is
just the raw text and then that purple
row is what we call the lemma which is
the canonical form of a word so we can
see that the word is help
the lemma is actually helped so if you
want to count the occurrences of a
particular word you can use the
canonical form so that helps and help
don't count as two different words and
then in the red row we get the part of
speech verb noun and adjective etc and
then finally we get additional
morphology details on each token in our
sentence so that's what the syntax
annotation looks like so it's with the
speech and natural language api's they
work in many different cases but there
may be situations where your system has
a lot of different custom data custom
entities that you're looking for and in
this case you would want to use
something to build and train your own
models and I'm going to hand it over to
a poor to talk about cloud machine
learning engine sounds good thank you so
imagine I was talking about a customer
service request a customer phone call
coming in talking very agitated and
saying hey my shipping was not delivered
so again using speech API you have
transcribed that audio into text using
sentiment analysis using natural
language API you have figured out this
is a very negative comment as a result
you your system so far has identified
this is a very high priority call that
you need to route next thing you need to
know is what kind of request it is is it
a shipping request it is about pricing
issue it's about support issue so on and
so forth and this is where your cloud
machine learning API sorry the cloud
machine learning engine comes in so to
do this classification of whether the
particular request is a shipping request
or a pricing request you will use what
we typically call text classification
text classification is pretty simple
what you do is look at a document or in
this case email or any audio conversely
do text and classify it into a label a
predefined label that you have relevant
to your use case so classic example
sentiment analysis essentially is an
example of text classification what
you're doing is looking at document and
classifying whether this is a positive
document or any
talking about in terms of polarity same
thing with document classification so
you can not only just do a particular
document classify as to one label you
can say this ticket is about shipping
and pricing so because the customer can
talk about more than one subject in a
particular email so that's the example
of text classification and building a
text classifier traditionally required a
pretty detailed understanding of the
underlying algorithms and the
infrastructure with tensorflow and cloud
machine learning engine all this is
simplified to a significant degree a
typical text classification on a
customer service would look like this
there are two steps involved in any
building any classifier one is the
training step and other is the serving
step in the training step what you're
doing is is taking incoming a set of
label documents in this case it will be
service request labeled as shipping or
pricing issues or customer service rep
issues and so on and so forth if you'd
you feed that in and train the
classifier and the way you should train
the classifier is basically extract out
key features that you train the
classifier on in this in this case the
features could be awards or bag of words
or sentence so on and so forth and that
you feed your classifier premium model
and once you have trained your model if
you bought the results that you expected
in terms of your test data you then use
that crane model on a cloud machine
learning engine to serve for a
production environment in the production
environment is pretty simple you get a
new state new service ticket you are
send it to the classic classifier being
served on the cloud machine learning
engine outcomes the label in this case
whether it's the shipping request or
surprising recurrent so on and so forth
so this is again I we haven't want to
typically as text classifier using
tensorflow because tensorflow provides a
set of very sophisticated libraries
helps you do the pre processing and the
post processing context very easily so
I'm hiding a lot of those details here
but no more than 80 lines of code you
can build a coil classifier and and so
for example in this case the very first
step is you are using you can specify
the model you want to use
the classifier so here in this case I'm
using a bag of words bag of words is
doesn't take into account the order of
the word so for example it will take for
shipping requests as long as they're
words like shipping delivery date of
delivery and so on and so forth it will
classify that request as shipping
request and for pricing if there were
surprising discounts and so on and so
forth that we use it to classify the
model will use that classifier is a
pricing issue so that's the very
simplified bag of works you can try out
different models as per you need and the
accuracy that you need and again the
sense of flow allows you to sort of
change the model in very simple ways and
once you trained up the first thing once
you specify the model to use Ukraine
your model and then you run your once
you've paint the model you run the
prediction and that's how and then you
typically you will run this predicted
model or a train model on a cloud
machine learning engine so that's it
again
very simple it went from step one speech
API using language API now text
classification to router ticket thanks
support so we've heard about a few
products that can help us with this but
to get a really good understanding of
it'd be good to see a real customer use
case I'm going to bring up dan from
okata
everyone welcome Dan hi dan dan is a
head of data at Oak Otto and he's been
in IT for twenty plus years and always
been passionate about data driving
businesses forward so Dan could you tell
us a little bit give us some background
on Oh kado and explain a problem you're
trying to solve with machine learning
sure
so this slide kind of says it all we're
an online supermarket we're based only
in the UK so quite a few of you probably
want to heard of us what it doesn't tell
me was in fact we really will largest
dedicated online grocery business we
have about half a million active
customers and a revenue of 1.5 billion
dollars and we've been around 17 years I
think that's the time that Diane said as
an average
yesterday which was a bit funny and have
basically innovated in disruptive
the grocery market in the UK since our
inception we actually have a sounds and
engineers so a more technology company
who run retail and operation logistics
businesses than a pure play retailer and
those operations are kind of part of the
model we run what we call CFCs customer
fulfillment centers these are
large-scale
automated warehouses by large scale I'm
talking about four football pitches as a
footprint four stories high with about
20 miles worth of conveyor belt within
them they basically take product in from
suppliers on pallets and then they
distribute the moment at the other end
as individual items for customer orders
the process about 10 million items a
week and complete an order every two and
a half seconds and we have two of those
that what we call are kind of legacy
ones now because it's part of disrupting
the industry we disrupt ourselves and
we've recently created a new model of
warehouse it operates as a hive a three
dimensional dense storage grid with
robots running over the top of it which
basically give us an increased
efficiency and increased accuracy and
all this technology and all this
operation efficiency is all because we
want exceptional customer service the
grocery market is extremely competitive
around the world but in the UK
especially and you need a compelling
offer to the customer and you need it to
be to be consistent and reliable because
if you get it wrong they will move our
warehouses allow us to offer a wider
range than anybody else about 50 Styles
and grocery lines and we achieve a 99%
fulfillment rate on that to the customer
but you know it doesn't always work and
as much as we've applied machine
learning in
side of our warehouses to improve the
way the product flows and is laid out
and as much as we're intelligent about
segmenting and personalizing our service
when we get a customer problem it always
comes down as a curve said to emails or
voice and when you get to a scale that
we're at now dealing with those emails
can be a challenge and that's where we
hoped machine learning would would help
us so how are you using a natural
language processing and machine learning
and specifically Google cloud platform
products to solve that problem okay so
this is a typical contact center ie it
was our contact center an email would
come in from a customer it would go
behind the queue and eventually we get
to the front and be processed you can
see that regardless of the type of email
regardless of the importance and the
sentiment that queuing system just
worked now we get about 2,000 emails a
day into our contact centers and we
resort our contact centers to deal with
that
where it becomes a problem is if we have
a rogue network problem it's the UK we
get can bad weather then then actually
that operation can slow down and and the
emails can double even triple and so we
wanted to come up with a way to
basically prioritize so we could get rid
of the Q & as approve had explained that
kind of bringing structure to these
emails so the idea here I love your
website these are typically emails I
have to say I have children so it's
easier for me to do shopping online that
is classified it's feedback it's
positive and that's how we are able to
then take that forward now we used
natural language API initially and that
did some great work in the
classification and really good in
sentiment but the structure of our
emails and the language our customers
used means that we need a bit more of a
bespoke model and certainly the tags we
want applying are very much fitting to
to our business
so I suppose it's talked about we
thought well we'll look at using
tensorflow we actually store all of our
customer emails as an archive we have a
corpus of about 3 million emails stored
they were actually all stored on premise
and before we push them into GCS we had
to do a load of data prep we wanted to
remove all of the personally
identifiable data people do put credit
cards that like the demo today you know
people can be a little easy with their
information so we we run some
pre-processing and once that had been
stripped out we tokenized it so we kind
of retained the meaning we push that
into GCS and then basically ran a
training of a model and once that had
been built
we as approve it suggested put it into
cloud amel and it now sits in front of
our contact center and in real time
receives the email works out what it
believes that subject matter is what the
sentiment is what the priority is and
then pushes that back into the queue in
the correct order basically the model is
a convolutional neural network we have a
word embedding layer followed by two
parallel convolutional layers we have a
performance measure of naught point
eight and the model was trained using
word to vac as an initialization into
the word embedding we found that it
worked really well on our corpus and and
so we retain that and we've trained with
a sigmoid cross-entropy loss over 20
keep ours
so how is implementing all of this
machine learning functionality impacted
your business and maybe if you share any
lessons you've learned during the
process a little bit click on the click
I want max so we put this in in December
run it in parallel basically to to
animal contact center queue and we've
got some stock results we were four
times quicker at risk
to negatively sentiment flagged emails
than we were responding to the positive
ones
so that was brilliant so there was a
definite distinction and differentiation
there and actually is a base level we
were three times quicker responding to
those negative emails and if we haven't
applied filtering so that was fantastic
and ironically we haven't actually had a
bad day since so we haven't got to
measure for what it does when we spike
but that was some fantastic results and
then as part of kind of better data we
actually found out that about 10 percent
of those emails don't require any human
interaction at all and that kind of
things like thanks you know something
like that and if we auto close those
then we can save redeploy for full-time
employees in the contacts and there it's
going to save us sort of around about a
hundred thousand pounds a year and as
the model itself only costs us a
thousand pounds a year to run inside of
cloud a mail engine that's about a ten
thousand percent ROI here it's huge and
but those weren't the only things that
kind of come out with I mean obviously
would have been great if that was all
and but we did have some key lessons as
you asked firstly we learnt that we had
to define our success criteria really
well and this is actually the business
and the development team for the
contacts and who came to us with the
problem and they were using measures
like time for first response and things
like that actually what we found is that
wasn't a great magic is it ignored the
sentiment it kind of ignored the
long-term compounding if it's my first
issue does it stop me shopping know if
it's two or three yeah so so we have to
work with them on on getting better
measures so we can actually tell if what
we were doing was better the other thing
we found is be really careful when you
kind of define your control groups and
run a/b tests when you
playing about with customer service you
don't want to get your test to roll and
you want to identify as soon as
something might be wrong and then the
other thing was the initial feeling that
this was all about contact center
efficiency and headcount actually was
was not borne out either by better data
we're now able to spot when products are
starting to behave abnormally from a
refund level and sometimes that's
something we do operationally to do with
the way we've received or store product
if we respond to that quicker we can
reduce refunds going to customers
refunds are basically bad products so
that's a great customer service benefit
and we can also respond to people going
I'm not going to be in please cancel and
that means we can free up resources on
vans and use less picking pick less
product less waste and then the better
data also we can then expand out into a
lapsing model we now understand not just
you contacted the contact center but it
was positive or negative it was about a
product and that helps us build better
lapsing models because now we know the
contact but but then more than anything
and it's a relatively soft benefit we
now really understand how to build these
machine learning models how easy it is
and with the right kind of thought it's
kind of opened up vast opportunities for
us to work on this definitely so what's
next for Okada I do have any future
plans for more machine learning oh yeah
yeah so this is only the beginning
really for the contract centerpiece we'd
love to apply this to social networks as
well contact center would Louis be able
to pick up trends from there we want to
go more into conversation as well so
more on the speech side could be on the
retail side or from from a customer
service point of view we're also looking
now at deploying machine learning models
for demand forecasting our forecasting
is great at the minute we only have less
than 1% of sales is waste but we think
we can get better and so the
opportunities are vast within the
operation great thank you so much for
sharing
[Applause]
thank you so next I'd like to bring up a
poor van regime to talk about PwC
another customer use case then this
totally changes the perception of a
grocery store does it how many times do
you think machine learning and like is
being used in such interesting ways and
this is this is unique in a way because
not every customer that we work with has
a data data science team and we are
privileged to have that head of data
science here but what if the customer
doesn't have a reticence dry steam and
want to achieve the same set of sort of
impactful results and this is where the
our partners such as PwC come in so to
talk about how customers are working
with PwC to build an end-to-end solution
I'll hand it over to Rajeev to talk
about it
thank you proof so I'm going to talk
about one of our customers Oscar Larsen
and how we help them with machine
learning how we help bring optimization
to their business but to set the
expectation I think Google has a great
technology stack across all kinds of
things and I always joke with my friends
that you know Google stack is good
because it can recognize Indian names in
the in the voice recognition thing which
is very hard to do and yeah and in Oscar
Larson is a company that that's a PwC
client and they service gas stations and
they run the largest such service
company and they have a huge challenge
across different parts of their customer
support organization they have a
challenge across how do you optimize
recording of the calls that come in from
different gas stations about what might
be down how do you make sure that the
field engineers who go out there have
all the data that they need they have
all the right equipment that they need
the parts so they're well equipped and
they don't have to do a return trip
and at the same time we also wanted to
analyze how we solve the problem that
parts and other such inventory are not
stuck out on the trucks of these skilled
engineers and they're using the right
things for the right solution and Larson
as a company they wanted to scale from
being a dominant player in five states
to grow across the country and what PwC
was able to do is we were able to bring
this business data to kind of train the
machine learning algorithms and use the
Larson data along with the proprietary
data that we were able to bring to build
them a solution that could help them
scale and the way we did this so we kind
of when you look at the system that we
built for Larson essentially every time
a new call comes in that the left side
and initially we first try to extract
whatever useful concepts and entities
that we can extract from there it's a
little bit like one of the slides that
Sarah had earlier where we use the
Google cloud NLP API to extract whatever
concepts we can get and we also want to
extract whatever sentiments that we can
extract from them it's slightly
different from a problem of kind of
disambiguate weather JK Rowling is the
write author or not when you have to
deal with the statements like hey my
pump is owned it is a positive sentiment
statement but you have to try to analyze
why is the pump down what could the
problems be and that's what I'm going to
show you as a demo so to analyze the
problem that comes in we take all of the
data that we have access to from Larsson
they get over 50,000 support calls a
year and they've been doing this for
over ten years so there's a huge data
set that was available for us to use as
training data and we also look at what
parts were actually sold to the
customers to fix different issues and so
we know that a problem came in a certain
part was used to fix it and we use that
as training data to figure out for
future
problems what kind of parts might be
relevant and using that the ML system
that we built it recommends three
solutions
anytime somebody calls in to Larson and
says there's a problem it figures out
who's the most qualified engineer who's
the engineer who knows how to fix that
type of fuel pump or that type of
point-of-sale terminal it figures out
what are the right manuals and documents
that he might need on the ground to
refer quickly to fix that issue and we
have all of those stored in Google Drive
and the machine learning automatically
links the in real-time links these
Google Docs to the context and the last
part which leads to the most cost saving
for Larson is how it recommends the most
relevant part I'll show a quick demo of
this if I can switch over to the other
screen
so it really generation yeah well we
Indians have as many machine learning
experts as a gas station owners so so
for this context let's assume a perv is
a gas station guy who really doesn't
know much about what the problem could
be in his gas station and this is what
90% of the problems that the Larsen
customer support team looks at you know
they could get a problem as simple as
something like you know just my pumps
are down and in most cases these people
don't know how to describe anything more
than that they have no clue what makes
up a pump I've had an education this in
the last six months for I've been forced
to study this but most people don't know
so that the system figures out from a
historic pattern of all of the all of
the problems it intended best cloud NLP
on the fly to first figure out hey are
all the pumps are down are they down on
diesel pumps under the pumps it tries to
get some more context and if I say for
example all puns are down on unleaded
and then it understands that hey if it's
a problem with just one pump then it's
probably something to do with parts that
make up a specific fuel pump and then it
looks at things like breakers and hoses
and things of that but if it's something
to do with a lot of bumps then it's
probably something to do with
communication to the pump or motor or
something that so first it picks up it
also has a Google Maps API integrated
with it so it picks up the location it
picks up where of who was calling from
he was definitely not calling from New
York but were you that's a gas that's a
real gas station in New York and once he
confronts his location it picks up what
type of gas pumps there are in that
location and
[Music]
and then it it diagnoses the issue to
say that it's probably something to do
with the motor or a filter and it now
sends this information to the field
engineer who's been assigned to that
case it also picks a field engineer who
is equipped in fixing motor or filter
types of issues and I can show you a
little bit more under the covers of
what's happening so this is a simple
representation of the recommendation
engine that we've built and so when that
chat bot looks at the back end it first
tries to figure out what's the equipment
on the side and then based on
recommending the issues let me just
refresh this
okay
so first analyzes that particular site
and figures out what type of equipment
there is on the site and once it
understands that it goes on to try to
analyze the problem and this is where
we're using tensorflow and we have a
single layered neural network - we
created a single layered new neural
network to solve that problem and once
it figures out what could be the
different equipment that could be a dove
that could be causing the fault it
creates a simple Bayesian probability
analysis of that and then assesses that
is probably due to a motor or a filter
fault then the hardest part of this
product was to try to figure out what's
the right part that could solve that
issue and this is something that we're
picking out of literally several hundred
thousand parts on the fly and once it
finds the right part it also recommends
the right documents that that field
engineer would need to refer to fix that
issue on type can come back to the
slides so I think one thing I'm sure the
audience want to know what what is the
infrastructure and what are the
technology choices PwC made in sort of
building the solution so could you tell
more about that yeah sure so this is
what our architecture looks like and we
chose we chose GCP primarily because a
lot of the tools that we need - we've
tried a lot of different tools and for
example if you look at the bottom of
that slide where we have all of the NLP
and ml components so we use the natural
language API and we use the cloud
machine learning API and tensorflow and
when we have a lot of these call records
a lot of these are not entered in full
sentences these are filled engineers who
are entering stuff on their phone
it's broken language it's a lot of code
words and item numbers and part names
and things like that
so it's very hard to process that type
of data with just a cloud with just a
natural language processing and because
there's a good tethering between the NLP
API the machine learning and creating
the noodle Network and executing it on
tensorflow in the Google framework we
chose that platform and on the right
side you can see the legacy data which
is the data set that Larson had for over
10 years and we migrated that data to
essentially a cloud sequel database and
we use firebase on top of it along with
bigquery to create indexes that we can
query and the front-end is all built as
is a we've different apps for the
dispatcher we have apps for the call
center people field tech people these
are all Android apps which all access
code to App Engine so that's the the
reason we chose TCP was it really
provided all the elements we needed from
the front end to the back end to the
machine learning piece thank you so to
wrap it up I think as you can see if you
are if you thank you
who as you can see if you are a customer
who has a data science expertise in
house you can directly use our products
as is if you want to build an end-to-end
solution you can work with our SI
partners such as PwC to build it into a
solution tailored to your needs so in
terms of external resources these are
the places where you can find more
information
[Music]
[Music]